I thought were really just going to jump right into this.
Um,
and so I have questions for each of you.
We're also going to have time for audience questions.
So at that time if you guys could line up at the mics and then we'll kind of go
back and forth until time runs out.
So that's okay.
Um,
the first question is for Matt,
so just kind of ground us in this story.
Like how did you become interested in the project?
Um,
and why did you decide to tell the story?
well a story core,
the oral history project,
um,
that you may have heard of,
they have recording booths around the country and people do long form
conversations that are archived at the library of Congress,
um,
and that are also used to create a radio pieces on NPR.
So they had approached me because they had a queer history initiative.
Um,
and they asked if I could help them find interesting stories.
And I had heard of the phenomena of intergenerational gay adoption,
um,
in a pre marriage era and was interested in finding stories related to it.
Um,
and so at the time I was working with a producer who is Walter's knees,
Eric and Nagel,
and,
um,
she had to call Steven Spielberg.
So on the bone that evening,
she said I had to cold call Steven Spielberg.
And I said,
I had to cold call the owner of a clothing optional bed and breakfast.
She was adopted by his older lover in the 80s.
And she said,
oh,
my uncle was adopted by his lover and his name is Walter.
So I went home and I googled,
you know,
Walter Nagle or last name and she failed to mention that Walter's partner had
been Byard Rustin who I was a huge fan of.
Although I feel that a lot of people don't know who he is.
Um,
despite a very acclaimed documentary called brother outsider that came out in
2000 and I believe in,
that's how I had heard of buyers.
So,
um,
you know,
that's how the whole project kind of got started.
Yeah.
Thank you for that.
And whilst there,
I feel like we all have so many questions for you,
but I can just ground death in one.
Um,
so you were 27 and buyer,
it was 65.
And so I mean,
just intergenerational interracial,
like just tell us about,
you know,
like that experience,
embracing those intersections and like what were some of the challenges and what
were some of the beautiful moments?
Well,
when I look back on it now and I,
you know,
here he,
us that kind of a question.
I mean it seems like,
Gee,
I mean,
how did,
how did we do this?
But it was all very,
very perfectly natural for us at the time.
Uh,
as I said in the film,
I was kind of an old 27 and borrowed was a very youthful 65.
Uh,
and we really,
you know,
we really shared a common,
common values,
common ideas,
common interest.
And so,
you know,
aside from just kind of being attracted me at the time,
I was attracted to older guys.
That can't be the case too much anymore because they're not that many that are
older than me,
so I've moved in the other direction.
Um,
but,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
we really just had a camaraderie.
Um,
just a very comfortable,
it was very,
it was very easy,
very,
very quickly.
Uh,
I think,
you know,
within two months,
I mean,
I was still on this kind of San Francisco idea,
but about two months after we left,
I mean,
after we met,
um,
we just kind of agreed that we were going to stay together for awhile.
So,
uh,
as far as the,
you know,
and when we were in a ratio,
we're intergenerational,
we were same sex.
It was like,
you know,
what else could there possibly be that could be thrown up on our faces are held
against this,
but we just,
you know,
kind of move forward and,
and you know,
people that loved us and people that cared for us,
our friends,
our family,
they were all cool with it was,
it was very comfortable.
Yeah.
And then Shawn,
you know,
someone who studied academically,
race and ethnic studies,
um,
and also someone who was also younger and also African American.
Like how did you first learn about bio Breslin?
Um,
and,
you know,
what were your thoughts kind of before the film and then how has the film
informed,
you know,
how you think about him and how you think about his legacy?
Yeah,
so I'm going to try to get through each question here.
Um,
but I arrived at Byard Rustin when I was in college.
I,
you know,
I consider myself a very good student of history prior to college,
but I noticed in our history books,
Byard restroom was purposely left out.
Um,
and you know,
given what we know about us history and how it's taught k through 12,
um,
we know that black history general generally has a very small portion are
located in those history books.
So it makes sense why Byard would be left out as a marginalized person,
uh,
being queer.
Um,
but having arrived at him in college as I was coming into my own sexual identity
as a black gay man,
um,
I took hold so Byard,
in a way that a lot of my peers did not.
I really wanted to research him and study him and learn a little bit more about
his life.
Just so that I can see how things have changed since he kind of lived his life,
kind of came into his own sexuality,
live within the movement as well.
Um,
and see,
you know,
kind of how that can kind of put some kind of focus on what I'm doing,
where I locate myself within the black queer community today and the 21st
century.
Um,
so watching the documentary was very eyeopening for me.
I had previously known that,
you know,
by addressing,
had been in a long term partnership with someone who was white.
Um,
having had been,
uh,
very,
you know,
this thing which president within the civil rights movement.
Um,
so I,
I took very serious interest in this because,
um,
I considered it a very hot button issue for a lot of people.
People would consider that to be,
um,
kind of taboo as you mentioned in the documentary.
Um,
so,
you know,
seeing the documentary really plants or perspective how his,
um,
how has Quaker upbringing really helped him come to terms with some of the
decisions he's made,
especially when it came to his personal life as well.
Um,
so just seeing how those things kind of overlaps,
um,
how his personal politics,
kind of channeled into his,
um,
his love life,
as well.
Um,
I think it was cool to see those,
those layers there.
Yeah.
No,
thank you.
And I love how they're like three distinct,
um,
kind of different views and perspectives on buyer.
And that's what really we're really looking to kind of show here.
And,
um,
this is a question for all of you and feel.
Matt,
I was reading an article,
um,
that you were quoted in and you talked about buyers creative resistance.
I don't think you can talk a little bit more about that.
Um,
and then the,
so if you can talk about that and then the question for all of us,
um,
is what type of creative resistance do you think is needed?
Now we're in very,
very interesting time,
you know,
in a multiple levels.
Um,
so just using this idea of creative resistance,
like what do you think we can extract from that for today?
Um,
something I was thinking about while making the film is this continuum of things
that,
uh,
seem radical at one time in that become kind of more mainstream or accepted
later.
So,
uh,
intergenerational adoption,
I'm sure to most people seem like a radical step to obtain equal rights,
but now gay marriage,
um,
this part of the mainstream.
So I think that's a key kind of helpful framework to look at,
um,
creative resistance now,
in terms of conceptualizing things that,
uh,
break rules or reimagine what rules could be,
um,
uh,
with the knowledge through history that that rule breaking,
um,
sometimes becomes absorbed into the culture as something mainstream
buyer trees.
Buyers' resistance was based on nonviolence,
on his Quaker upbringing.
And the whole idea about nonviolence,
it's really based on love.
And so,
you know,
you go into the creative phase of resisting with the idea of eventually building
community.
I mean,
the community is fractured and you're trying to heal it in some way.
And so that kind of means that you're not going to be screaming in somebody's
face or calling them a pig or calling them,
you know,
a racist comment or something like that.
You're going to try and bridge the gap that already exists.
And so that was kind of really the framework that fired,
had to operate in.
And so we had to come up with really,
you know,
creative,
a creative demonstrations,
creative marches,
ideas that were really uniting people as opposed to just broadening,
broadening the gap.
And I think there exists such a gap now there seems to,
in in the society that we have that we need those kinds of creative thinkers and
creative resistors more than ever
when I'm thinking about creative resistance,
um,
I always come back to what we're doing within our own communities to resist the
forces that my tear us intro in the intro community away from each other.
Um,
when I think about intersectionality about being black and queer,
um,
specifically and given the challenges that we're up against socially and given
the current political environment that we find ourselves in,
I think it's more important than ever that we have serious conversations in our
community about what we're doing is marginalized others who look like us,
who come from the same backgrounds as us.
I think it starts at home for a lot of us in terms of having those serious
conversations before we talk about,
um,
you know,
extending the hand over to other communities.
Not saying that they should happen separate from each other,
um,
or it shouldn't,
they should,
when should happen before the other,
but saying that,
you know,
we should be resisting,
um,
creatively and strategically different ideas that would pull us apart from one
another.
Um,
specifically within the black community or specifically within,
within the queer community.
And a lot of people actually find a queer community to be very isolationists in
and of itself,
very white and very male and of itself.
Um,
we obviously know that's not true,
right?
So we have a lot to do internally as well.
Um,
in terms of rectifying things that have been done,
um,
in the past,
I have been wrong and to have marginalized people within our communities.
So basically resisting those internal forces that can disrupt it.
Thank you.
No,
I think as I reflect on,
um,
buyer in this film,
I'm struck by the fact that it just took me so long to learn about him.
Like I think that I was in college,
um,
when I found out about him,
and identifying as a black queer man myself,
it was just so comforting to know that his presence was there.
You know,
his legacy is all throughout the civil rights movement and still lives on today.
Um,
but he is like still largely unknown in a lot of spaces.
So kind of before we go to audience questions,
Walter,
I would love for you to kind of tell us like,
what's the one thing that,
that we,
we wouldn't know about buyer and that we wouldn't get from the documentary.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Um,
because I think this,
this document and kind of compliments whether outside or a great deal,
because some brother outside do you see bar debating Malcolm x,
you see buyer and podiums talking and pointing his finger and you know,
very militant and yeah.
You know,
I think this,
this,
this one kind of shows a softer side of him.
Yeah.
Um,
I think probably,
you know,
the fact that he was so human,
he was so gentle,
he was a very approachable,
I mean,
he was not somebody,
even though he had achieved a certain,
I guess you could say rank or position in the civil rights movement,
you know,
that really didn't happen until after the march on Washington in 1963 and so he,
up to then he had kind of lived as an itinerant freelance troublemaker,
if you will,
kind of making this subsistence living.
And you know,
um,
so he wasn't really very full of himself,
I guess.
You know,
he didn't go around with bodyguards,
limousines or anything like that kind of thing.
Um,
so I,
I think just the fact that he was really so human and warm and really always
willing to,
um,
reach out to people.
Yeah.
Uh,
especially young people.
I mean,
Bard was one of the leaders who was really known too.
It was an inspiration and because of his radical politics,
especially in his younger years,
young people kind of gravitate to him because younger people tend to be more
radical.
So when Stokely Carmichael was coming up,
uh,
people like that,
they,
they really went to buy it as opposed to going to why Wilkins or Whitney young.
Yeah.
They went to Bard and they went to Ella Baker.
That's,
that might be a name that is familiar to somebody because they were really the,
they were the voices within the leadership of the movement that we're kind of
edgy and progressive.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I think,
um,
you know,
just his,
his spirit of youthfulness in his spirit of creativity.
Uh,
something that,
you know,
it was very important to his legacy,
to his life.
And again,
something that,
uh,
we need now.
We need creative young people at,
they're not relying on all the old methods to make change but to,
to forge ahead and use the tools that we have now.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
So do you have any audience questions?
Um,
I would love to know are,
have you speculate as to what,
uh,
Byard would be thinking and doing today in terms of the political landscape,
in terms of where we are with,
um,
gay rights,
with things that are happening within the black community.
Where do you,
where would he be positioned right now?
Well,
I think he would certainly to be pleased with the progress that's been made over
the last 50 years.
Uh,
he would have been disheartened by the 2016 election and,
you know,
maybe depressed for a day or two,
but,
uh,
we would have gotten up two days later and gotten right back in the fight and
started,
you know,
starting resisting.
Um,
yeah,
I think he,
okay.
You know,
Byron a Philip Randolph,
they dealt largely with the issues of racial discrimination and segregation and
Jim Crow,
you know,
in the,
in the forties to the 60s.
But then once some of those laws were passed and there was a civil rights
legislation,
the voting rights act,
they way they really understood that the larger issue is poverty and economics.
And that's something that is,
is still witness in his,
you know,
the income inequality has broadened over these last years.
And so the work that he was doing in the mid sixties to work that Dr. King was
doing at the time they need died,
the poor people's campaign,
I think those would really be issues that he would be focusing on.
And you know,
I think a little less so on identity politics,
but more on bringing people together on the issue of economic justice.
And something I think about often,
um,
is it paid was a lot today,
where he had been involved in any of the,
um,
the political fights that black queer people are facing in this country at this
time.
Um,
you know,
as I've done research about Byard,
I've found very little of him,
you know,
engaging with black queer people of his generation.
Um,
and that's been something that has always been like a gray area for me.
Like I'm just like,
Hey,
I'm sure he's probably done work and he's probably,
he probably knows tons of people within the Black Creek community.
But similarly it's a Baldwin I often question,
you know,
how,
what their ties were liking if they would kind of be the champions for Black
Queer,
um,
you know,
political issues that we're facing today as something I think about all the
time.
It's just something that I wish I had more context.
So thank you for asking that question is something I think about too.
My name is Ryan.
I'm so my question is,
so how do you think,
um,
like kind of just like having like an interracial relationship is different deck
then it is today and kind of going off a little bit more of that.
Is that,
would that be considered like,
you know,
like empowerment within like the black community or is that like kind of
discouraged or frowned upon to day outside of your racing going against the
cause of like black empowerment?
This is often something I think about it as well.
Um,
like
given the documentary and seeing where Bayard Rustin comes from as far as his
Quaker upbringing,
I think that gives us a lot of context into how he went about,
um,
you know,
engaging in relationships,
um,
which is very different.
And then also considering the fact that he was,
you know,
apple under Martin Luther King instead of like say a Malcolm x or,
um,
you know,
someone who more left.
Um,
I think that often can provide some insight into how he thought about,
um,
interracial relationships.
But I think at the time,
I mean,
I didn't live there,
obviously I didn't live back then.
Um,
so I don't have as much context there,
but,
um,
I would imagine that there were a lot of questions that people had,
to his relationships.
Um,
and I think in a lot of ways we can draw parallels to today.
I think interracial relationships are obviously less taboo than they were,
um,
you know,
50 years ago.
Uh,
that being said,
there are a number of conversations that we have honest conversations that we
have,
especially when it comes to black leadership,
black people who are visibly,
um,
out there who are representing communities,
about,
you know,
the relationships that they answer and how oftentimes they can portray,
um,
something that might be different than what their work consist of.
Um,
that's something that I interrogate often.
I don't really have an answer to it.
Um,
I just think that we like more the things more chain.
This is the way that more things change.
It's like more things stay the same I guess in a situation.
Um,
but yeah,
it's a very,
uh,
tricky issue.
I guess.
I like to add a few things.
I think you really have to look at the whole context in which we were living.
Um,
first of all,
they're always been people who have been against interracial relationships.
Their worries were and there still are and they're probably always will be.
Um,
there wasn't a gay movement.
I mean,
during the,
during the time that I met Bart there was,
but in the time that he was maturing,
there was not really much of a gay movement,
just speak of,
there are a few organizations,
but um,
you know,
they weren't very high profile,
high visibility.
Uh,
and certainly,
you know,
I don't know,
I mean,
I don't know how many out black gay men you could name from his generation.
Maybe you could name more than I could.
I mean,
people always refer to James Baldwin,
a wooden barn,
you know,
had a relationship with James Baldwin and a friendly relationship.
And like they occasionally appeared on panels together and work together and
that kind of thing.
Um,
but bard was different because he was out there.
He was more authentic.
He didn't lie about who he was.
It was a generation of gay men,
regardless of color,
who we made in the closet,
who married marriage is convenience,
if you will,
so that they could advance their careers,
had families,
you know,
Bard didn't do that kind of thing.
So the number of people who are really living their authentic selves in,
in Baldwin was one also,
uh,
were very few.
So in terms of,
you know,
pool of applicants,
I guess you could say for having relationships for Bard,
having relations with people,
it was not that great.
If you think about,
you know,
besides the percentage of gay men in the world,
percentage of black gay men in the world,
the percentage of black gay men in the world who had an education who were
interested in nonviolence,
who were political.
I mean,
you know,
it keeps getting smaller and smaller and smaller.
A bar did have relationships with black gay men,
sexual relationships.
But in terms of longterm partners,
that's really about values.
And,
um,
they're just,
you know,
the pool of applicants,
if you will,
was just not that great.
We've had a few conversations internally about,
um,
Jen,
mostly a white folk,
uh,
sort of working on narratives around folks of color and the inherent,
a strong problematic areas that we can get into by representing other people's
stories,
um,
that involve experiences that we will never be able to experience as,
as white folks.
So I'm curious,
a question for Matt is,
um,
did you encounter any challenges since you were telling Walter Story?
Certainly,
but this was also a story about bard.
I'm curious whether you encountered at any challenges,
I'm trying to sort of create an artistic narrative of a man of color,
um,
knowing that that was not your experience.
Recognizing also that directors do create stories about people that are not
exactly like them,
but this might be a particular,
I could imagine this being a particular challenge.
So I'd be interested in hearing how you approached that.
Yeah,
I think about that a lot and I do make films.
Um,
mostly not from my point of view,
but from the point of view of a character's,
for lack of a better word.
Um,
and while thinking of this,
I do ask my self the question,
this is a great story.
Um,
am I the person to tell it or is my job to get out of the way and let other
people tell a certain story?
And,
um,
in a sense,
even though I made this film,
um,
because I chose to do it entirely from Walter's point of view.
Um,
he's,
he's telling this story,
uh,
which is a story of the civil rights movement,
but through very particular personal lens.
Um,
and Walter has been such a,
um,
amazing ambassador for Byrds legacy and that's part of the reason I didn't feel
like,
um,
the film needed additional points of view to historicize Byard.
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
I think there's been recent films like a film about Martha P.
Johnson where,
um,
these issues have really come to the fore,
about,
um,
you know,
uh,
authorship and,
um,
kind of,
uh,
I guess as white people getting out of the way sometimes instead of talking and
listening more.
So,
um,
you know,
it's sometimes a limitation to my ex,
my ability as a filmmaker.
And I think about that
by addressing was like totally inspirational for me in college as well.
Um,
the movie brother,
outsider and his early life as a communist and it's like Congress,
like his debate with Martin,
with Malcolm x,
like thought those where he was like really interested in his early politics.
I guess.
When you met him,
did you know who he was before he introduced himself before he introduced
himself to like,
we're like,
oh that's,
he's like this big shot.
Like how was that?
What was that like just as a personal experience?
Like,
well,
it was an ma at the moment that I met him.
I wasn't sure I knew who I had known who buyer dressed and was,
but bard was no different carrying a walking stick cane.
Well,
oh,
it's only a can if you need it.
He didn't need it.
There's a walking stick,
you know,
style accessory.
So,
um,
he didn't have it with them that afternoon,
so I wasn't sure,
but you know,
he introduced himself.
But I had known because I was interested in the movement in my,
in my high school years,
and Barb was showing up in the press quite a lot.
I,
you know,
I knew who he was.
It was,
hmm.
Well,
thank you so much,
Matt.
Walter and Sean.
Um,
it's really been a treat for us to bring added screening to Google and the
partnership with the,
it gets better project.
Uh,
thank you for that.
And also,
I just want to thank you guys for humanizing buyer for us,
um,
and,
and bringing home at this notion of love and respect and creativity.
Um,
and I think that that transcends time and space.
So thank you all so much.
Thank you.
[inaudible].